have you ever had bad news but you just
don't know how to properly deliver that
bad news to someone
we're going to talk about that today
hi i'm patrick bedeville host of
valuetainment weekly so
how to deliver bad news you see as an
entrepreneur whether we like it or not
bad news is always going to happen
whether
a software is not being designed on time
or you didn't deliver on that sale
whatever it may be
bad news is part of your business and
delivering bad news
is something you need to learn how to do
because if you don't it leads to
delaying a time bomb that may happen
later on so let's go through
a few different steps with how to
deliver bad news number one first thing
about bad news
if you can find a way to solve the
problem before it gets to the source
do it so even the bad news never
actually happens because you solve the
problem
number two consult advisors about how to
handle that bad news
immediately don't take your time and say
next week tomorrow whatever maybe
as quickly as possible consult your
advisors about the bad news
three nobody likes surprises with bad
news if something's gonna happen with
bad news let your team know a week two
weeks a month three months six months in
advance
just like companies say hey in the next
six months there's going to be layoffs
they don't come and say here's what's
happening when they do it that way
it leads to issues resentment tell
people in advance
that here's what's happening with bad
news here's four
always deliver bad news early there is
no benefit from delaying
a bad news from having to be told to
somebody
deliver it as soon as you can to that
individuals
ceos especially like to hear bad news
early on so they can find a way to solve
it
point number five take responsibility if
it was your fault
say it was your fault one of the things
that annoys
ceos or entrepreneurs or leaders or
anything is when somebody is not willing
to take responsibility
a person who wins is where they are
because they take responsibility
leaders like it when a person comes in
and says hey guess what i messed up it
was my fault it was nobody else's fault
but here's what i think we can do about
this so deliver it and take
responsibility on your own
point number six there's always a silver
lining and any bad news or problem that
comes up so come up and say
let me tell you the bad news here's what
took place it was my fault
but here's what i think that we can
learn from this
this is what happened like a coach will
say we lost the championship well let me
tell you something how many teams make
it out here
we learn an experience we can come back
next year strong we can do this
hey here's what happened here we lost
this account but we learned that this
doesn't work
with clients like this the next time we
come to a client we need to take this
approach
point number seven is deliver bad news
with solutions so listen
here's what happened this is what took
place i take responsibility
we learned that this kind of approach
doesn't work but here's what i think we
can do with this client
i think if we were to have our executive
call this person
instead of myself to just kind of do an
assessment with them and let them know
that we appreciate them taking the time
maybe we can get them to be willing to
have a third meeting with us
give a solution to whatever bad news you
may have
and last but not least whatever the
solution you gave
it is on you to follow through with the
solution
for your ceo your leader your
entrepreneur your teammates whoever that
works with you
to increase their beliefs to know that
every time there's bad news every time
there's a problem every time there's a
challenge
you always come through with a solution
and you always follow through with the
solutions
and you get them solved that's my
message of the week to you and please be
sure to subscribe to this channel and
comment on the bottom
you're going to go outside have you ever
had bad news but you just don't know
how to pro have you ever had bad news
but you've never really